Aurora challenge is life for us and Kiev
and can you explain just how much ground
Ukrainian forces have been able to
retake in this latest round of fighting
well the ukrainians are carry on pushing
uh in the area that Charles was
reporting from there after taking that
to important town of liman they are
carrying on uh trying to stop the
Russians from setting up new defensive
lines keep on keep on going uh into
neighboring towns around Lima and places
like Tosca but really the attention at
the moment has now switched down south
to the Herson region now for some time
many many weeks the ukrainians have been
trying to squeeze and isolate Russian
forces in kerson City and surrounding
areas which is on the West Bank of the
NEPA River trying to isolate those
Russian forces from the main bulk of of
Russian troops which is on the other
side of the river in the main bits of
course on uh region now it seems that
the ukrainians in the last few hours
have found a weak point in Northern
parts of the Russian occupied territory
is there on the West Bank of the nebra
and have broken through and have now
pushed a significant amount of distance
along the riverbank now the uh the
President zielinski Vladimir zlenski is
is staying quite tight-lipped about
exactly how much territory has been
taken he said that two settlements have
been liberated arcanagalska and Mira
lubiska but actually it looks like the
ukrainians have gone further than just
those two Russian military bloggers have
been sounding alarm uh talking about you
know a possible collapse in Russian
forces there so that's that's a very
active front line at the moment there
have been a couple of uh cities uh hit
by strikes airstrikes overnight
zaparizia at nepro have both been struck
by by Russian missiles and the Damage
that's been done there is being assessed
at the moment
or a challenge for us in Kiev thank you